wie doof ich allerdings wirklich bin
meine lieben freunde finden wir im
heutigen video raus denn wir machen
sieben rätsel die deine gehirnleistung
testen er ist durch geschätzt würde ich
sagen ich hoffe nur ein test nummer 7 ok
los gehts mehrfach einen genauen blick
auf diese beiden abbildungen welchen
fehler haben beide gemeinsam
die augen sind auf beiden bildern nicht
umgedreht
ich will mich noch immer nicht
herausfinden kannst klar drehe das foto
auf den kopf es sieht schrecklich aus
ich habe den mund vergessen die augen
und lippen beider frauen sind umgekehrt
[Musik]
ich bin reinste stück elend sache ist
dass das gehirn es nicht gewohnt ist die
augen und lippen in dieser position zu
sehen so
also 20 von sieben aber
das ist schade dass manche menschen
ihre zungen umkehren klicken den like
button wenn du einer von ihnen bist
du es kannst dann mache dies und die
würde dann die linke seite deiner zunge
sie wird die berührung von der
gegenüberliegenden seite spüren denn die
evolution hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
no way
eine stunde später
zwei stunden später
zwei sind jahre später
hier lernt hier heute noch
richtig was testen
hätte meinen youtube-kanal darauf dass
das jetzt hinkriegen
dass er sich vielleicht nicht sagen
sollen wie viele löcher hat dieses t
shirt wie 123456 78 er auf beiden seiten
wirklich gut die frage spezifiziert
nicht wie viele löcher das schon
ihr könnt ihr main kanal abstauben
ich glaube niemand will meinen kanal
attest nummer fünf ganz kurz
bevor wir hierzu test nummer fünf kommen
ich habe jetzt einen punkt
es ist schon doppelt so viel wie ich
gesagt habe dass ich kriege wie würdest
du diesen baum benennen würde ich nicht
benennen
baum
da kommen wir denken uns namen aus
frederik flic flac die namen die den
sinn kommen im kommentarbereich auf doch
schreibt mal bei mir hier schreibt mal
runter wie würdet ihr ein baum denn
[Musik]
ich hatte mal einen baum früher als kind
ein apfelbaum wissen wie steve jobs
doch die tatsächliche herausforderung
darin
den getarnten vogel auf den baum zu
bemerken habe ich gesehen
aber es ging darum wie man den baum
nennt
und da gibt's keine richtig oder falsch
was juckt mich diese kappe da drauf wenn
du dies getan hast gut gemacht das war's
ich wusste aber anrufen
ja bin ich da mit dem niveau verbunden
test nummer vier
ganz kurz immer vor den von den tests
pause ich hier aber ich gebe mir der 14
punkte
2 von 7
das ist mir wahrlich und kannst du dies
in fünf sekunden schaffen 50 24 sekunden
doch versucht es schnellstmöglich zu
lösen can you stayed hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 grünen gelb wir also fünf sekunden
sind ist schon rum 123 4000 57 45 67
millionen 5,2 millionen 789 um die 5 und
bei mir um die drei die zehn fehlt der
fehler liegt nicht in den zahlen oder
ihren farben
[Musik]
buseck ich bin sein onkel test nummer
drei da geht's siehst du ein verstecktes
baby ja
ja
wahrscheinlich
wenn du den dünnen äste des baumes
ich habe eigentlich gesagt dass da 1 ist
also wie ich mir jetzt auch ein punkt
vergeben test nummer zwei final
countdown
welche linie ist länger
[Musik]
da muss irgend haken sein
irgendwo da mussten haag
es kann ja nicht einfach sein das war
jetzt länger ist ich habe gar keine
ahnung ich glaube dass eine fangfrage
ich glaube es ist wirklich einfach es
länger das ist offensichtlich oder
punkt
aber warum kommt die frage damit rein
das ist er da wollen die verwirrung
stiften oder wie fünf personen wurden
gefragt welche der beiden linien länger
war vier der getesteten personen wurden
gebeten zu lügen die personen logan sehr
überzeugend sodass die testperson nicht
standhalten konnte und die falsche
antwort gegeben hat was
dann hat das aber nichts mit der aufgabe
an sich zu tun sondern einfach mit der
aufgabe jemand einen witz erzählt in
jeder lustig findet dann hast du auch
wenn er wird einfach scheiße ist dann
mag ich nicht
dazu betreibt hat eine verdammte fresse
halten perfekt machen wir so test nummer
1 der letzte test kannst du microsoft
gesehen
herzogs g8 es ist der von
da
relativ schnell
der von monster ag hier ist er noch sehr
anders
bevor jetzt schluss auswertung kommt
erst mal meine auswertung
alles richtig sprechen wir nun war deine
testergebnisse so wären auch mehr als 20
sekunden für die beantwortung jeder
frage gebraucht hast oder nur
ich habe auch nie pausiert oder so es
fällt ihr schwer über das offensichtlich
hinauszublicken und du kannst nicht
einfach mit veränderungen umgehen und
was wenn ich
alles
innerhalb von ein paar sekunden richtig
beantwortet habe plus zusatzpunkte wenn
du weniger als 20 sekunden gebraucht
hast dann ist ein gehirn recht jung
morgens aufgaben aus verschiedenen
winkeln angeben ja so kann ich kann aber
auch wie sehe ich auch so
noch so ein paar sekunden später
was ist dein ergebnis verrate es uns im
untenstehenden kommentarbereich
muss man auch einfach mal dann sagen
[Musik]